the Joe Rogan experience yeah no no for
other people it's like super rewarding
like it's a selfish thing to be generous
and kind selfish in light ways because
it really helps yourself well that's the
whole mantra of growing up in America is
you need to help yourself and you're a
loser if you don't get rich and all this
[ __ ] it's all these impossible
you know goals that we can't do without
actually help from each other no the
biggest losers rich people who are sad
right god damn right you're rich and
you're still depressed you're super
successful and you're still depressed
like wow you you built a shitty house
like your foundation sucks I mean cause
like your foundation yeah who you are as
a person like the way you treat people
the way you view the world the way you
love your friends and your family like
that's your foundation and if you become
successful and you have that foundation
I feel like you can still be happy but
if you become successful and you just
[ __ ] that foundation away because you
just wanted to make it I'm just gonna
make it [ __ ] all that stuff I don't need
that debt I don't need love I don't need
any of that and then you make it and
you're just sitting there alone yes it's
a good [ __ ] tomb that's why I think
that's why a lot of people like Trump
because they think of him and like I've
actually heard this term like a
blue-collar billionaire it's like what
he was given a million if everyone's
given a million dollars from their Pappy
it was a couple million yeah a couple
few couple million from their daddy yeah
you'd probably have it a lot better off
small loan of a couple big deal lievable
dude to him that is a small loan now
that's what's really bizarre
yeah he's someone I think Matt Taibbi
described him best he's like what a
stupid poor person thinks of as a rich
person oh my god yeah and his idea is
just to throw money at everything like
the palestine-israel thing could you've
seen Jared Kushner's hold layout of like
this is the new peace plan no oh my god
it's literally just let's give them jobs
meaning let's have corporations like
basically profit off the occupation
what's interesting to me is that even
right-wing Trump supporters in
particulars is a right-wing Trump
supporters do not seem to like them do
not seem to like Jared Kushner
they don't like the fact that his
daughter is working in the white house
and that the son-in-law is there running
things like they're very disturbed by
that they don't like that yeah
nepotism I mean well what's weird is
they just blow with the [ __ ] wind man
I saw Fahrenheit 11 nine totally
recommended to everyone what is
listening Michael Moore's newest
documentary oh my god it's amazing but
the first 20 minutes just shows like how
Hilary lost and it shows that Jared
Kushner actually lobbied to have sicko
in theaters all across the guy mean he
was for socialized medicine and he was
like working hand in glove with Michael
Moore to roll this out it just shows you
how fickle they are and like how they
just have no actual values yeah just try
to make money this is a great idea you
know his voice is really high yeah it's
super weird I will see the two them
together it makes its verse there so you
can't believe I have sex I think they do
no I think you jerks off with a cup she
squirts it in there and she kicks him
shows just how bizarre and inappropriate
Trump is with the banca but there's this
one talk show where the host is just
like Ivanka she's like what what do you
haven't most in common with your dad and
she's like real estate and golf and
she's like Trump what do you have most
in common the bunkin he's like well I
would say sex whoa yeah that's like what
father says that well like what do you
have most in common with your baby sex
that's it just in common just in common
was super just Freudian like I want to
[ __ ] her but I can't because she's my
daughter
he just says so many crazy things I just
I think that guy is just always talking
you know and that when you're always
talking over get a chance to really
contemplate what you're saying he's just
talking and then once you talk like so
many times during the campaign trail it
just seems like you would say things and
then you would just have to like justify
what he said you know I've done that
when I was younger I would say something
stupid and then I would have to try to
figure out a make that stupid thing make
sense right right
Trump's just constantly goes 20
seven-year-old man favorite thing you
have in common with your father either
real estate or golf Donald with your
daughter well I was going to say sex but
I can't relate that that's the crazy
thing is he thought about it and decided
he wasn't gonna say yeah yeah I was
going to say he's on Wendy Williams and
he wanted people to scream want to say
just a good opportunity to say sex there
was a whole montage of creepy [ __ ] that
he said like he would date her you know
he when she was a baby he was like she's
gonna grow up and hopefully have big
tits or whatever like he said really
hates Tiffany because she's not because
she's not attractive oh that's the the
one yeah with Marla maples is that the
other daughter a good good point I don't
actually know who Tiffany's I mean I
think he had her with Marlo who's very
attractive so it's weird but that is
weird
yeah something happened some sort of
across inbred lighting but he just
pretends like she doesn't exist it's
kind of sad well
[Applause]